[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les amis le stress de Reddit vous avez
beaucoup plus mais alors du coup après
ça je me suis baladé sur Reddit et mec
c'est génial c'est une mine d'or il y a
des strettes qui parlent de tout et de
rien et il y en a un qui m'a fait
particulièrement rire qui s'appelle
crapi design en gros c'est des photos du
quotidien d'endroits ou d'objets du
quotidien mais qui sont mal foutus mais
vraiment très très mal foutu à tel point
qu'on se demande comment c'est possible
que des mecs et fait ça sans se rendre
compte de la connerie aujourd'hui nous
allons ensemble regarder les meilleurs
de ces images alors ce que j'aime bien
avec redit aussi c'est que dans les
trade les images changent tous les jours
ou toutes les semaines vu que c'est un
système de vote par exemple si tu as vu
ce serait il y a une semaine et que tu
retournes dessus aujourd'hui bah il y
aura des nouveaux trucs et c'est ça que
j'adore bref je découvrais dit un peu
après la guerre après que tout le monde
sache que c'est mais bon mieux vaut tard
que jamais comme on dit dans le milieu
quand on est un looser alors je le dis
très souvent ça commence par ça ok donc
là je suis juste confus sur ce que je
dois faire quand je me retrouve dans
cette situation
mec panneau excite panneau qu'on utilise
en plus si jamais il y a un feu tu vois
et là là vraiment il y a le feu t'es pas
bien et tu es au pied du panneau sorti
tu as réussi tu vas t'en sortir non non
gamin cette porte n'est pas une sortie
c'est horrible mec c'est en plus c'est
quoi c'est pas une sortie mec je suis
désolé comme ça c'est totalement des
sorties ça se trouve c'est une sortie et
le mec a mis ça pour faire genre que
c'est pas une sortie comme ça s'il y a
un s'il y a un feu les gens meurent
je regarde beaucoup trop de Thriller et
de reportages sur les psychopathes ça
pas du tout ce banc qui charge des
téléphones à l'aide de l'énergie solaire
est placé sous un arbre dans l'ombre
d'un immeuble
ça coûte grave de la thune en plus de
faire ce [ __ ] de bord mettez-le au
moins là où il fait beau je pensais
qu'on avait appris ça quand on avait
quatre ans
une vraiment le dos d'une tasse bah
voilà c'est rond quoi ça peut vraiment
pas aller dans le carré d'une assiette à
moins que le carré soit plus grand que
le rond mais là ça ne marche pas du tout
celui-là est un peu un grain je vous
l'avoue parce que c'est évident que
cette assiette est faite pour servir des
expresso dans des toutes petites tasses
tu sais et lui il a demandé un café
allongé voire américain sans fils de et
du coup le serveur était triste parce
qu'il a que ses assiettes là il sait
qu'elle rentre pas dans le carré bref
ouais je prends la défense de tout et
n'importe quoi ouais orange c'est quoi
le problème
[Musique]
ah bah oui ok j'ai compris quand je
comprends je me mets un doigt dans
l'oreille c'est bien ça c'est un savon à
l'orange normalement à savoir l'orange
dessus il y a des photos d'orange mais
là comme c'était Halloween ils ont mis
des photos de citrouilles alors les gens
étaient troublés et penser que c'était à
la citrouille alors que non c'est à
l'orange quand on voit un frigo ou un
légume sur un produit et ben on imagine
que le produit sans le fruit et légumes
en question si je suis en train de faire
une thèse sur du savon c'est bon clément
il faut qu'on prenne des vacances
[Musique]
quelle horreur oh mais ils l'ont mis un
[ __ ] de poteau devant sa porte
d'entrée non mais c'est pas possible
s'il est malin il peut devenir hyper
musclé en un an il se fixe une condition
dès que je sors ou rentre de chez moi je
fais le drapeau sur ce poteau pendant 10
secondes emballées les muscles arrivent
en fin d'année comme ça avec le bonus de
prime de salaire un vrai c'est horrible
hors night is great
arrêtez là tous les petites usines là
toutes les petites usines là les petites
usines mimi là arrêtez de sortir des
produits dérivés fait avec le cul il
faut les faire avec vos mains des fesses
ne sont pas capables de les faire
correctement je vous assure le placement
du capteur dans cette salle de bain ah
oui il est trop loin et du coup il faut
tout le temps ramener ta main
ingénieur je veux faire beaucoup
d'années d'études pour embêter les
utilisateurs de toilettes ok il y a
problème de conception maintenant je
vais te dire un truc au moins c'est
clair le capteur est loin il faut mettre
ta main devant pour que l'eau coule des
fois gros le capteur est proche mais il
marche pas tu mets ta main tu es là tu
es comme un con tu fais ça là sous l'eau
là pour qu'il détecte c'est tu tapotes
dessus là comme ça c'est chiant on en
parle pas assez de ces capteur qui
marche pas non mais en vrai
qu'en américain dessine [ __ ] pourquoi
il flèche et un gun mec les flèches sont
même pas dans le carquois ah comment je
suis supposé lire ça c'est quoi cette
merde c'est quoi qu'est-ce que ça fait
là ah c'est que ça doit parler d'huile
ou un truc comme ça et du coup ils ont
voulu montrer de quoi il parle mais ils
l'ont mis sur le texte c'est malin faut
pas écrire des livres quand on sait pas
faire
oh j'adore ce cube magique c'est pas du
tout à qui ah mais peut-être c'est la
marque juste en fait ça s'appelle le
handsport donc tu as voulu faire une
blague alors que tout est clair sur ce
packaging c'est pas bien
[Musique]
les mecs mais quelle idée en plus il y a
de l'herbe partout autour quelle idée ça
me rend fou la vraie question quand on
voit ça c'est qui a posé le deuxième bon
qui et quel bon est le deuxième qui a
tort dans l'histoire
donc célèbre restaurant asiatique et ils
ont mis un chef italien oh nique la
logique et il est content il est content
en plus d'être là de représenter l'Asie
est-ce qu'il a même 1% d'Asie en lui cet
homme non une crise your ass améliorer
votre fessier comment tu vas faire des
erreurs de tipo comme ça c'est de la
prod au lieu de mettre ça comme ça où
tout est compréhensible ils ont mis ça
comme ça on dirait que ça veut dire
giant as qui veut dire Q géant c'est
génial
comment l'esprit humain peut-il être
super vertu il y a vraiment un semblant
de testicule là c'est pas du tout un
motif sexuel regardez petit test pour
vérifier si vous avez l'esprit perverti
ou pas
le quoi condam exactement est-ce que
vous pouvez me dire je n'arrive pas à
lire
[Musique]
si vous avez lu anal vous avez l'esprit
perverti kayak
c'est pour ça que le a de gauche est
plus gros que le a de droite moi je vais
pas vous mytho je l'avais vu direct the
what kundown
et je n'ai qu'une parole vous le savez
les mecs vous faites une partie trash et
une partie recyclable on voit bien qu'il
n'y a qu'un sac qu'il n'y a pas de
partie ne faites pas genre si c'est pour
mettre qu'un sac en dessous arrêtez un
peu on voit nous ah
non franchement le gars vous avez pas
pensé que je comprends votre entreprise
vous les montrer aux gens qui rend les
dents blanches et tout qui les je
comprends très bien mais mettre trois
[ __ ] de blanc ensemble avec en
dessous marqué White Power c'est pas bon
il faut éviter à tout prix comme faire
une vidéo qui contient des hommes
politiques
est-ce que vous avez une porte genre
pour aller sur un trottoir allez c'est
un terrain de pétanque
plus troublant sur cette image c'est que
si j'y vais j'ai vraiment envie de
passer par la porte j'ai pas envie
d'enlever j'ai envie d'ouvrir ce truc là
et de leur fermer derrière moi pour
montrer je suis dedans c'est
psychologique non ça me fait pas ça
c'est génial du coup des choses sur le
cerveau humain ses vidéos là c'est la
recherche c'est travailler ah tiens
tiens tiens Asus et Républic of Gamer
cette poignée n'est pas homologuée c'est
pour rattraper les scolios qu'on chope à
force d'être assis de travers sur nos
chaises genre c'est plus simple à porter
quand la poignée n'est pas centrée je
viens de faire une théorie pour vous
défendre hésitez pas à m'envoyer un PC
Gamer sur cette vidéo je vous aime ok
les amis là c'est fou tu es en soirée un
pote renverse un peu son verre sur toi
tac tu tapes dans son verre hop tu en as
plein l'épaule mais tu as aussi très
envie de faire pipi tu peux faire l'un
ou l'autre pas les deux en même temps
ton dernier espoir c'est quoi c'est
tombé sur ça mec tu peux te sécher
l'épaule pendant que tu pisses non en
vrai la vérité ça va être horrible il y
a un mec là là qui est comme ça qui met
ses mains sous le truc comme ça mais tu
veux pas te déranger pendant que tu ris
on a quand même envie d'avoir les mains
sèches avant de retourner au repas c'est
terrible oh les dedans il manquait un
cube et ils ont mis deux lettres dans le
dernier du coup c'est l'enfer ça fait
partie de ces images hyper
insatisfaisantes venez dans ce cotise on
lui donne le dernier cube non c'est trop
triste
c'est quoi cette affiche et mec
franchement c'est un crapi design mais
il est bien fait genre l'endroit est
respecté on a visé l'entre-deux on a pas
dégradé de franchement c'est clean on
doit tous balader avec un tuyau comme ça
la vie serait bien meilleur ce plug USB
brille plus que le soleil
je le veux c'est génial mec t'en
branches partout sur toutes tes prises
chez toi et tu fais une soirée tu as pas
besoin d'acheter de l'ail tout quoi
c'est déjà ambiance non c'est une idée
de merde ok le gars est sur un jeu
mobile et apparemment c'est un jeu qui
réservé pour les majeurs donc le jeu
même si t'avertissement et veut qu'un
parent accepte que son enfant il joue
les mecs ont une idée ils ont mis une
interface s'il te plaît peux-tu
confirmer que tu es le parent
responsable légal en complétant ce
calcul 68 - 59 genre il y a que les
parents qui peuvent résoudre ça mec mon
gars même Natsu il s'est résoudre ça je
te jure faut arrêter la peinture dans
ses toilettes publiques oh quelle
horreur
on dirait qu'un enfant a joué avec du
gâteau au chocolat ok ici on a un
pommeau de douche apparemment qui est
pas bien oh ils ont mis la barre de
l'autre côté c'est génial je pensais
même pas que c'était possible mec
les ingénieurs des poubelles se sont
alliés avec les ingénieurs des escaliers
pour créer leur plus belle pièce
franchement c'est beau ça nique le
couloir du milieu mais c'est beau bravo
les gars c'est chouette
le mec acheté un mug et sur le code
barre qui a coulé le magasin il y a
marqué ok pour le lave-vaisselle et le
micro-ondes et quand tu retires
l'étiquette le constructeur de la de la
tasse lui a marqué non pas ok pour le
micro-ondes c'est du foutage de gueule
mec c'est fou de faire ça c'est vraiment
des bâtards oh non là ils ont déconné là
là c'est hyper grave le t-shirt
PlayStation les couleurs de rond carré
extraordin ne sont pas respectés ils ont
inversé les couleurs ils ont mis le
triangle bleu au lieu de le mettre vert
ils ont mis le rond vert et le mettre
rouge et oh ça bouge le cœur je veux pas
aller plus loin effacer moi ça ça dégage
on finit sur celui-là il est parfait
c'est un panneau qui dit qu'il faut
ralentir parce qu'il y a une aire de
jeux d'enfant bah ils mettent ça ils
mettent vraiment ça mais les mecs là
qu'on consulte pas nommer vos enfants
mais dites-leur que c'est pas comme ça
qu'on joue mais regardez pas faire quoi
il y a pas que c'est normal si vous en
font joue comme ça c'est pas normal je
suis désolé de vous la prendre mais là
pour vous on dirait que tout le monde
joue comme ça non les amis c'est la fin
de ce petit tour sur le stress design de
Reddit ça m'a bien amusé j'en ai vu
plein d'autres aussi qui sont sympas
dans la vraie vie ça m'intéresse si vous
croisez des des trucs comme ça qu'on le
design qui a pas du tout tout est moi
faites une petite photo et tout est le
moi pensez à moi mettez-moi bien je suis
très friand ça me fait trop rire c'est
trop marrant de toute façon l'erreur
bête est gentille sans conséquence ça me
fait toujours rire c'est à côté mignon
autour de ça je trouve c'est rigolo je
vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine
vidéo pour parler ah bah je sais de quoi
je vais vous dire d'ailleurs
[Musique]